ces prêts pour l'interview suicides
n'ont pas forcément évasée c'est moi qui
me suicide interview suicide
joey starr bonsoir vous avez conforme là
jo c'est quand les gens sont crispés ils
ont arrêté de faire l'amour
je vais me faire masser au bout de trois
questions
joey starr bonsoir verre en forme
comment ça va me sortait de prison là si
c'est pour des questions que c'est juste
une chose à [ __ ] qui devrait glisser
vers moi j'aime bien vaccinaux plus tu
auras traduit par toi même et j'aime
bien l'accident ça veut dire tu vas
signer du pays j'ai conscience à chester
ça fait longtemps vous êtes a frappé une
hôtesse de l'air a vouvoyé le train ou
quoi non ça me manque
comment va votre singe ouais c'est pas
le mien c'est vrai que vous l'avez
manger en vrai en fait
en fait chez nous au bénin et la banque
au môle est l'avion de changement on a
dégusté mes vacances dans deux autres
voitures spéciales voilà mais ces bons à
rien de s'avancer à la texture du poulet
c'est pas mal hein
il n'y a pas des maladies abbas qui
paraissait pas c'est par le change qui
est arrivé le sida un message r d qui
gère des fonds levés thuir un jour je
suis allée chez des amis en guyane elle
j'ai mangé c'est marrant mais les grands
parents qui est arrivé tak tak et
c'était bien avant l'histoire du saut
dray et gens comme on dit chez nous ils
ont ramené du bon
getac tacle de vous ramener des trucs
dans de l'alu il arrivé la veille et il
faut chauffer un truc ils l'ouvrent et
c'était un sage et on se servait en fait
la farce à l'intérieur on servait qu'à
la patte était grillé ce qui était en
fait on le tas pour attendrir la viande
alors il c'est toi ou lui tu fais ta rue
suisse et toi combien je crois qu'on va
changer l'interview chez moi même si moi
franchement une certaine de terminer
voilà pour les migrants qui ne pas venir